et bienvenue à vous ravi de retrouver ça
vous regarde tu es parti version d
confiné voici le sommaire stop qu'ovide
et si c'était la solution les députés
viennent de donner leur feu vert à cette
application permettant de tracer les
malades afin d'endiguer l'épidémie alors
en quoi cet outil numérique peut être
utile est il vraiment indispensable
quelles garanties sur la protection des
données personnelles et sur nos libertés
publiques on n'en pas dans un instant
avec nos invités
un homme un homme est en colère ce soir
sa proposition doit été vidé de sa
substance par la république en marche
elle visait à revaloriser les salaires
des femmes de ménage c'est invisible en
première ligne dans la crise sanitaire
cet homme c'est le député françois
ruffin il viendra se frotter à la
majorité sur ce plateau tout à l'heure
enfin le jour d'après nouvel épisode de
notre collection d'entretien thématique
ce soir le deuil
comment at-on pu laisser quelques
semaines nos proches mourir seul à
l'hôpital à cause du coc vide le
psychiatre et psychanalyste serge hefez
nous éclairent et témoigne me voilà donc
pour le programme hashtags hébert ça ça
n'a pas changé on est à
[Musique]
et merci à vous chers téléspectateurs
d'avoir choisi lcp à la majorité donc
les députés ont voté pour cette
application stop qu'ovide cet outil
numérique je vous disais destinées à
casser les chaînes de contamination
trois heures de débats vifs dans
l'hémicycle avec un gouvernement et la
garde des sceaux en tête qui n'a pas
ménagé sa peine pour rassurer
cette application n'a pas vocation à
devenir l'alpha et l'oméga de la lutte
contre la copie de 19
elle n'est pas non plus un prétexte pour
que l'état se transforme en état
policier
contrôlant les faits et gestes de nos
concitoyens au coin et on veut en
débattre de cette application bonsoir
mounir mahjoubi bonsoir vous êtes député
la république en marche de paris ancien
secrétaire d'état au numérique et vous
avez accepté de dialoguer avec un grand
connaisseur du numérique ce soir bonsoir
jérôme colombain de france info vous
connaissez bien cette application vous
allez nous dire si oui ou non à la fin
de ce débat il faut qu on la télécharge
cette appli après après ce vote celui
qui va nous planter le décor comme tous
les soirs stop qu'ovide n'est pas
magique mais stop qu'ovide est utile
vraiment c'est ce que répète le ministre
et bien c'est stéphane blakowski le
regard de blacko sur cette appli si j'ai
bien compris c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
alors qu avez-vous compris stéphane à
cette appli j'ai bien compris
myriam et moi j'ai compris que les
français en fait tu avais peur de tout
mais en permanence quand on est des
sondages on a vraiment l'impression que
la majorité d'entre nous a la trouille
constamment alors histoire détaillée un
petit peu mon propos je me propose une
un passage en revue de quelques sondages
de ces derniers mois au mois de mars
parisien publié un sondage qui nous dit
que les français
la majorité d'entre eux ont peur du
virus à 61% bon la limite ça peut se
comprendre
un mois plus tard on est donc en avril
la majorité des français a toujours peur
cette fois ci ils ont peur du
déconfinement c'est un sondage de
terrafemina qui nous dit que 53% d'entre
nous ont peur du déconfinement alors
aujourd'hui on est en mai et puis bien
sûr les français continuent d'avoir peur
vous vous doutez bien cette fois ci ils
ont peur de quoi ils ont la peur de
l'application peuvent co lead c'est un
sondage de france bleu qui nous dit que
53 pour 54 pardon pour cent des français
sont inquiets par à l'idée que lors du
données personnelles puissent être
utilisés alors avouez que c'est quand
même assez étrangle c'est comme aussi
les français faisait beaucoup plus
confiance à mark zuckerberg cas edouard
philippe
ça les dérange pas de confier leurs
données personnelles un milliardaire
américain qui est propriétaire de bas de
droite sarah de facebook messenger de ce
facebook et diana
en revanche alors là pas question que sa
confiance au gouvernement un pur
pourtant l'application stone co lead
c'est simplement le prolongement
numérique des fameuses brigades
sanitaires les brigades salutaire et
l'application stopped vide
c'est exactement la même mission une
fois qu'il ya un malade est identifié
bah on cherche à identifier le plus vite
possible
tous ceux qui étaient en contact avec
lui lors des quinze derniers jours la
seule différence c'est d'un joker va
recevoir un sms et que dans l'autre
quart ben à recevoir un coup de fil mais
dans un cas comme dans l'autre y aura
aucune obligation de se tester
aucune obligation de se confiner et
aucune amende si on ne fait ni l'un ni
l'autre alors pourquoi cette règle de
nestlé swiss re l'application stop le
vide alors que j brigade sanitaire elle
ça ne faisait quasiment aucune
difficulté donc je ne sais pas mais
peut-être qu'il faut pas se demander à
qui profite cette fameuse peur des
français alors moi j'ai les deux
hypothèses
bon la première hypothèse c'est que ça
peut profiter à une partie de
l'opposition qui espère que cette peur
va se transformer en colère excès de
colère bavard tomber son gouvernement
la deuxième hypothèse mais là c'est plus
une certitude évidemment que la peur ça
a profité médias parce que les sujets
qui font peur eh bien c'est ce
effectivement qui vont aussi vendre mais
j'imagine que tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord avec moi sur le plateau donc on
va pouvoir en débattre
on y va tout de suite merci stéphane ya
beaucoup de sujets dans le papier de
stéphane notamment sur l'aspect non
obligatoire et donc l'efficacité de
cette appli mi-mai pour comprendre déjà
ce qui se passe ce soir un vote a eu
lieu
peut-être que voilà il va y avoir le
sénat mais bon quand même une majorité
ça va revenir à l'assemblée
qu'est ce qui va se passer ça veut dire
que l'application là elle va être mise
en oeuvre elle va être mis à la
disposition des français
ap robert comprendre le contexte
institutionnel cette mission de
développer l'application c'est une
mission l'exécutif c'est le gouvernement
qui a décidé de lancer ce groupe de
travail qu'il a voulu ouvert avec des
experts avec l'inria qui est un des
instituts les plus experts en france
même dans le monde et qui est un
institut public de recherche avancée en
informatique c'est le gouvernement qui a
souhaité aussi série c'est le
gouvernement qui a souhaité proposer au
parlement de s'exprimer sur le sujet il
n'était pas obligé de le faire ce qu'on
nous l'a conçu lesquels continuent nous
avons débattu et nous avons décidé à la
majorité que oui nous acceptions que
cette application puisse être lancée
maintenant c'est entre les mains de
l'exécutif d'exécuter et donc d'aller
jusqu'au bout de cette appli de la
mettre à disposition des personnes
cedrico annoncé ce matin
ce week-end où le début de la semaine
prochaine donc c'est maintenant qu'on a
tous pouvoirs la télé charrière très
concrètement vous voulez mais
télécharger je fais partie des testeurs
donc j'ai une version bêta
que que j'ai souvent pas le cas elle
bénéfice très concrètement pour pour
celui qui la télécharge vous souvenez à
l'assemblée nationale on a eu un des
premiers cluster de contamination aux
copies de 19 mois j'ai reçu un appel
un matin qui était un appel de la rs qui
me disait bonjour monsieur le député une
de vos collègues a été testée positive
elle est aujourd'hui hospitalisé et en
discutant avec elle
il se trouve que vous avez passé une
heure et demie avec elle en réunion face
à elle donc ils m'ont dit vous faites
partie des personnes qui dans ce cluster
sont très à risque
nous vous invitons un à vous rapprocher
de votre médecin et comme on était
encore en stade un an et demi deux et à
aller vous faire tester dans un service
d'urgence
c'est ce que j'ai fait et le test était
négatif quand j'en suis content ce qu'on
appelle le traçage parce que ma collègue
elle malheureusement c'est devenu assez
grave assez vite
elle était hospitalisée et on lui a
demandé de se souvenir de calcul avec
l'appli si je suis par exemple prenons
cet exemple moi dépistées positives au
corona virus qui valent déclaré sur les
violations ma collègue en plus de
répondre aux questions
elle peut se souvenir que des gens
qu'elle connaissait donc moi elle me
connaissait la famille elle la connaît
les gens que qui est qu'ils sont c'est
plus proche est incapable de donner leur
nom et leur téléphone par contre les
inconnus près de qui elle a passé du
temps auprès de qui elle a peut-être
tout sait pas de qui elle a peut-être
échanger une assiette une fourchette un
couteau cela ils peuvent pas être
prévenu mais là avec son application
elle va dire aux médecins j'utilise top
cow vide et le médecin veut dire bah
voilà le code à rentrer dans ce top cow
vide c'est un code qui permet de
confirmer que vous avez vu votre
diagnostic positif c'est un code de
sécurité pour pas que n'importe qui
puisse dire alors c'est soit un qr code
si on veut le faire une version visuelle
soit un code à taper et ça c'est stocker
nulle part c'est juste pour être sûr que
n'importe qui peut pas dire ça c'est le
laboratoire qui va vous le donner ou
c'est le médecin qui va vous le donner
et dès que je tape ça dans l'application
l'application va envoyer un message sur
le réseau à toutes les personnes qui
auront été enregistrées sur le téléphone
au fur et à mesure des 15es le dire très
concrètement jérôme colombain que vous
recevez dans ce cas de figure une
notification sur votre téléphone si vous
vous avez c'est d'être dans cet
entourage et que vous avez téléchargé
l'application une notification qui dit
quoi
attention ce avait été en contact avec
une personne susceptible faille
aujourd'hui testé positif donc vous êtes
sceptiques vous même d'avoir été
contaminés mais on ne connaît pas le nom
de cette personne se rend pas non non
non absolument pas puisque c'est
totalement
non pas anonymisées c'est pas le terme
exact ces pseudonymes ise mais ensuite
c'est à dire quoi on prend forcément les
noms des gens à partir des mobiles puis
ensuite on les transforme en pseudonyme
et puis on découpe le pseudonyme le
chiffre et on le stock dans une base de
données où personne ne principe ne va
donc il ya quand même un certain nombre
de sécurité c'est vrai que sur sur cet
aspect visible de l'application l'aspect
utilisateurs le but du jeu si on a bien
compris c'est de gagner du temps et en
même temps ce sera pas totalement du
temps réel c'est à dire que c'est pas
parce que vous allez entrer dans le
métro et que y aura peut-être 4,5 10
personnes porteuses du coronavirus
autour de vous que tout le tout d'un
coup tout va bip et ça va pas se passer
comme ça puisque en réalité il aura ce
sera surtout sur l'antériorité des
contacts
suite à la détection et à l'ordre avec
la personne contaminée le signifie on
restait sur le pratico pratique on n'est
pas géolocalisés justement c'est un
déjeuner pas surveiller c'est à dire
qu'on ne saura pas où sont sur le
territoire tout qui ont fait des
positifs les deux pays qui ont fait des
choix radicalement différent de la
france en a le cas d'israël ou de la
corée du sud dans ces pays
un autre choix démocratique est éveillé
leur s'assembler ont voté un avis en
israël on a donné aux services de
renseignements la capacité d'intégrer
l'intégralité des données des opérateurs
mobiles donc tous les données
géolocalisées de tous les endroits que
vous avez été dans la ville près de chez
vous loin de chez vous et c est le jour
vous est positif ces données là sont
mélangés toutes celles qui sont stockés
sur tous les habitants et renvoie des
alertes à tout le monde pas le choix de
la france est très efficace alors en
termes de protection des libertés
individuelles on est proche de zéro mais
encore une fois on juge pas ça dépend du
système culturel en france ce serait
inacceptable
donc qu'est-ce qu'on a choisi on a
choisi un système où on va noter les
interactions 7
ce téléphone numéro xxx a été près de ce
téléphone
xxx tout à l'heure vous avez dit rompre
en votre nom non cette appli vous
demandera jamais vu non à aucun moment
vous demande votre nom on sait pas qui
vous êtes et raison l'appli ne prend pas
le nom mais on sait joindre au téléphone
à l'épeautre alarmant pas très loin de
mon identité sociale a placé la question
des données des données personnelles
qu'est ce qu'on a comme garantie avec ce
stop qu'ovide sur nos sur nos données
qui forcément
vont circuler il ya deux façons de
protéger les données dans la vie en
numérique un cédant collecter le moins
possible ou pas du tout et deux si on en
collecte c'est de s'assurer qu'elles
sont pas toutes au même endroit et que
l'endroit où elles sont stockées il est
très sécurisé donc premier aspect en
collecter le moins possible c'est le
principe des codes de pseudonymes
isation et à la fin c'est pas mon prénom
votre prénom qui circulent entre les
téléphones ou avec une base de données
c'est un identifiant unique qui permet
juste d'activé de faire sonner une
application donnée elles seront
détruites elles sont détruites tous les
quinze jours sert que dès qu'une données
étaient stockées plus de quinze jours
elle est supprimée parce qu'en fait elle
est inutile au delà de 15 jours puisque
au delà de 15 jours vous êtes plus
contaminés donc le sujet c'est vraiment
comment je n'en prends le moins et
comment si jamais on se fait hacker son
téléphone
comment ça nous donne accès à rien ou
alors le problème c'est que c'est
absolument pas obligatoire puisque vous
avez choisi le volontariat stéphane
voulait intervenir là dessus mais alors
nous on a une communion de pensée à 10
ans incroyable que j'étais justement
c'est le terme de l'obligation qui
m'intéresse c'est moi j'entends les
critiques sur cette application en
disant oui à finalement l'état c'est
inutile elle a un côté gadget
parce que justement elle n'est pas
obligatoire est pour être vraiment
efficace il faudrait que le soit rendue
obligatoire
pourquoi ce n'est pas le cas pourquoi ne
cherche pas été efficace jérôme
colombain parce qu'on n'a pas le droit à
la cnil l'a dit dès le départ qu'il
n'était pas question que ce soit ni
obligatoire ni lié à une quelconque
récompense ou incitations et c'est alors
pas davantage si vous avez fait que
manger rien si vous téléchargez l'appli
tout à fait c'est bien mais moi ça
samassa m'interroge sur un point ça va
être comme être l'attitude que vont être
l'attitude des médecins
je vais chez le médecin parce que je
suis positif voilà le médecin qu'est ce
qu'il va faire par rapport à l'appli
stop que vider ce qu il va m'en parler
est-ce qu'il va pas m'en parler et ce
qu'il a le droit de m'en parler ce qu'il
n'a pas le droit de m'en parlait ce qui
a le droit de m'inciter à l'utiliser au
contraire comment ça va se passer
vraiment qu'est ce que qu'est ce que
vous allez faire vous allez inciter les
français il y aura de la communication
et les médecins qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'ils doivent dire parce qu'ils ont
aussi le fichier ils ont un autre outil
le fichier des puisque des malins
une mission une obligation qui est à
chaque fois que près d'un patient
positive se présente de suivre un
protocole qui est de demander aux
patients toutes les personnes qu'il a
rencontrées mais on est dans sa villa
s'ajoute à celle dans un pays libre si
le patient décide de mentir au médecin
n'y a pas une police qui vient vérifier
si vous n'êtes pas menti aux médecins
donc c'est pareil avec l'appli ya pas la
police qui vient vérifier que vous avez
aussi un secret médical en france qui
fait que est ce qu'il a il est où est la
limite il a le droit de dire voilà je
vous conseille de prendre cette
application l'a écoutée sur ce sujet je
vais pas m'aventurer seul ce soir à vous
donner ce type de recommandation ce que
moi je pense c'est je pense que c'est
important que le médecin dans sa posture
de médecins est toujours une information
neutre maîtriser contrôler c'est à lui
de décider en fonction des
recommandations sanitaires ce qu'il veut
donner à son patient en fonction de son
équipement de son haut niveau de
connaissance du sujet et de son état de
santé
pour revenir sur l'obligation parce
qu'on a fait on a très clairement une
ligne de crête entre efficacité d'un
côté encore et c'est obligatoire et les
libertés de l'autre on a le sentiment
qu'on a vraiment choisi les libertés
peut-être faut-il s'en féliciter mais si
personne ne télécharge cette application
si vous avez très peu en pourcentage de
la population non mais ce sera ce sera
un gadget ça servira à rien pendant le
débat pendant mon intervention j'ai
donné l'exemple de si jamais on n'avait
que 10 % d'utilisation dans le
territoire qu'est ce qui se passe
bon ba aujourd'hui on a 300 nouveaux cas
par jour 300 nouveaux cas par jour ça
fait trente personnes par jour qui
serait détectée positive écuyers qui
accueille aurait installé l'application
stop qu'ovide ça veut dire que c'est 30
personnes là il ya 10% dès gens qu'elles
ont rencontrées qui auront aussi
l'application qui vont recevoir une
alerte
bon bah 10% de 10% s'affairent pour cent
eh ben c'est déjà un pour cent de la
population qui à chaque fois que
quelqu'un va être détectées va recevoir
une alerte et si jamais la personne qui
reçoit l'alertent c'est un hyper spread
heures comme on dit un hyper diffuseurs
comme par exemple un député un député
c'est quelqu'un qui rend compte près
d'une centaine de personnes par jour qui
même quand il met son masque parle d'à
peu près tapote un peu les épaules prend
dans les bras salut tout le monde
si c'est un député qui reste chez lui
lui il a peut-être épargné 100 personnes
par jour à partir du moment où semih en
confinement ça c'est extrêmement
important
c'est pour ça que même si on n'a que 1 %
et la digestion les hypers jeunes actifs
qui rencontrent énormément de monde
eh ben ça va sauver les personnes plus
âgées qui sont chez elles
qui se serait fait contaminer enchaîne
vous êtes d'accord avec avec cette
analyse là parce qu'on se dit sans
obligation imaginons même que celle
appliquée social jamais passé si ça
avait été obligé mais ça aurait été un
carnage à l'assemblée enfin ça aurait
été une levée de boucliers il n'ya même
pas d'obligation par exemple d'aller se
faire tester si on vous dit vous recevez
la notification vous avez rencontré
comptable aucune obligation non plus de
se mettre en quarantaine si vous avez
été testé positif
donc on se dit bon on comprend mieux
pourquoi certains pays sont plus
efficaces que nous le dilemme depuis le
début de cette histoire un à côté on
reproche à l'état d'être trop directif
de parler aux bobos gens comme à des
enfants notre côté on dit on le peut lui
reprocher de ne pas être assez directif
et bon voilà ce que vous dites c'est une
ligne de crête
maintenant je pense que le véritable
intérêt de cette application c'est que
c'est une première et malheureusement ce
n'est peut-être pas la dernière mais au
moins on va tester tout le monde va se
tester le gouvernement va se tester
l'appli va être testé à dire qu'il
attend peut-être à nouveau besoin de ce
type d'application quatrième vague des
pandémies l'autre celle là où une autre
objection elle dit j'ai l'impression que
là on a une certitude c'est que jamais
les français jamais les députés
n'auraient accepté une application
obligatoire est important je crois me
souvenir qu'on disait un peu la même
chose on craignait un peu la même chose
de continuer en disant jamais accepté le
continent les français sont des veaux
pas réfractaire il ne le respecteront
pas vous verrez en fait tout le monde
est resté de tank et chez soi il a été
très bien respecté ce qu'on sait par le
même biais de raisonnement sur la paix
la demande de protection est très très
grande depuis le début de vie culturelle
c'est à dire que les gens étaient plus
prêts à accepter de rester confinés chez
eux que d'envisager quelque chose qui
est il faut le dire assez nouveau c'est
à dire que le risque fantasmer autour de
cette application
j'ai écouté les débats ce soit moi pour
moi la plus grande atteinte aux libertés
c'est le confinement ce que je trouve
terrible c'est qu'on empêche les gens de
se voir les gens de travailler les gens
de circuler les gens de s'aimer
ça c'est une atteinte majeure est
pourtant là tous voté lire on l'a tous
respecté et on a tous suivi très
patiemment les annonces du ministre de
la santé à chaque fois prévention sortir
ou pas hélas non nous expliquer
exemple qu'en italie il ya une demande
très claire sur la protection et la
santé par rapport aux libertés ils ont
été plus touchés que nous ils ont été
bouleversées par de nombreuses choses
après le débat italien n'est pas du tout
tranché il n'y a pas une majorité dans
le pays qui est prête à accepter des
mesures halal israélienne ou à la corée
du sud c'est à dire qu'il ya quand même
un équilibre en france qui est important
si on parle du confinement il faut aussi
noter quelque chose il ya des pays où si
on respecte pas le confinement on va en
prison en france
vous avez vu que pays de liberté si on
respecte pas le confinement c'est une
amende
elle n'est pas très élevé mais c'est
parce que on est un pays de tact et
mesure quand on utilise des mets des
mesures coercitives sur les libertés des
personnes
si jamais les français ne l'avait pas du
tout respecté on aurait eu un autre
débat à l'assemblée premier ministre est
revenu souvent en disant écoutez le
confinement avec 135 euros ça ne marche
pas donc je vous demande devait être une
amende à 1000 euros là on ne regardait
pas un peu plus dur et puis si les
français l'avaient toujours pas
respectés madiba faut renforcer ce qui
est intéressant c'est que notre pays à
respecter
donc l'état n'a pas cherché à faire plus
fort et le parlement n'a pas eu besoin
de se prononcer sur oui ou non on doit
faire peser sur les français un un poids
plus haut c'est vrai que pour l'instant
la place allez-y c'est les joueurs un
souci de la part de la majorité de la
part du gouvernement ne surtout pas
donner le sentiment que cette
obligatoire surtout pas passer pour des
ennemis de la liberté mais maintenant
que la vie existe
moi je balle mais tant que j'ai une
boîte de 100 personnes et je me dis ça
serait quand même moche qu'il y ait un
seul mes employés qui chope le collier
dès qu'ils foutent la boîte en chômage
partiel
est ce que il ya risque que les
entreprises par exemple force des
employés à l'apprendre l'application est
donc ça finalement la contrainte soit
pas officielle mais rêve
jérôme colombain il avait l'air de lever
sourcils et vous et vous répondrai après
non mais parce qu'il ya une réalité
c'est que on parle beaucoup de ce top
que vides qui est l'appli
gouvernementale mais il ya plein
d'autres applis il ya plein d'autres
solutions techniques qui sont proposés
mon peintre russe va t'il m'obliger à
télécharger alors ça a pris je sais pas
s'il peut obliger mais en tout cas il a
aujourd'hui des solutions à sa
disposition et cd débat qui risque
d'avoir lieu dans les airs c'est clair
hélas pas le droit de vous imposer
d'installer cette appli ça c'est sûr et
certain la misa justice l'a rappelé est
impossible
imposer l'utilisation de cette
application pour venir travailler mais
le débat que vous soulevez est un débat
de droit du travail actuel qui est en
train d'épuiser tous les experts et tous
les cabinets d'avocats et tous les
services des ressources humaines
que peut-on imposer à ses salariés at-on
le droit d'imposer un contrôle des
températures à l'entrée at on le droit
d'imposer aux salariés de poser d'avoir
un bracelet d'éloignement qui permet à
chaque fois de s'assurer qu'on a les 2 m
quand amazon se fait condamner qu'on lui
dit il faut augmenter ces mesures
qu'elle mesurait at-il droit de mettre
en place ce sujet est un sujet nouveau
nous n'avons jamais connu à cette
échelle des obligations de sécurité
il ya que dans les lieux hyper sécurisé
où on accepter des limitations libertés
des salariés c'est quand vous travaillez
dans une centrale nucléaire vous
acceptez beaucoup de choses vous devez
vous rentrez avec une empreinte
biométrique
vos données sont stockées vous n'avez
pas le droit d'accéder à certaines zones
il faudra imaginer que dans des bureaux
on va accepter des choses qu'ont
acceptée avant que dans des lieux très
sécurisé on a changé derrière moi pour
quelques semaines ou quelques mois d'un
mot ce débat était allé jérôme vous
voulez télécharger ou pas été chargé par
curiosité un peu par conviction aussi et
puis voilà mais je lui reproche quand
même une chose parce que je trouve qu'il
ya beaucoup de positif mais il ya une
chose très négatif c'est que on n'est
pas eu d'application européenne on se
retrouve avec des applications par pays
ça c'est un vrai problème pour
convaincre certaines frontières vont
rouvrir et que ça risque alors cédric
hall a rappelé rapide aura réussi à
faire la première application ensemble
mais la france a fait cette application
qui aujourd'hui répond à beaucoup des
enjeux qu'on s'était donné en commun et
on nous avons continuer le dialogue avec
les autres pays le dialogue continu avec
l'allemagne et nous on espère toujours
les convaincre de rejoindre l'initiative
qui n'a pas cessé et en fait il ya lille
7 ils sont parallèles initiative commune
continue mais chaque pays a lancé la
sienne ont mis au jour moi j'espère
qu'on va continuer qu'on va réussir à
fusionner autour du meilleur projet
allez vous rester avec nous ça va vous
intéresser c'est l'heure de la chronique
d'alex taylor chronique très british ce
soir puisque au royaume-uni alex sait
pas du tout ce top cow vie d'un qui qui
préoccupe c'est stop krings
expliquez-nous ça oui mais rien n'est
effectivement domnique coming est un
spad a special advisor conseiller
spécial ou même le préféré de personnes
s'était lui le prestidigitateur
qui a porté le break site et les
sélections de raz-de-marée à johnson en
décembre dernier alors le petit problème
c'est que en dépit des consignes que lui
même avait imposé aux britanniques
il s'est déplacé avec son épouse et les
2 6 ans et déjà être malade avec son
ghost quatre ans pour aller voir ses
parents adorent homs et à 2 170 miles
donc en gros un aller retour de plus de
800 kilomètres alors que tout le monde
était strictement appelés à rester dans
leur home sweet home
bon ok c'est pas très bien ce qu'il a
fait dominique caming mais est ce que
pour autant c'est une affaire d'état
alex non mais j'étais presque sait que
c'est pire si la sphère de confiance
savez tout à campagne du parti conçu par
camion lui même était autour de
lentilles élite de cliquer augmente et
la celle et vite
nec plus ultra surtout qu'on a pris que
dix jours après leur arrivée à de rome
ils ont passé un après-midi dans le très
beau château de barnard le jour comme
par hasard de l'anniversaire de ladite
épouse alors il a tenté de se défendre
en faisant une conférence de presse
lundi
oui mais c'est là que c'est devenu du
est-ce parce qu'il à expliquer cette
petite escapade à ce château
en fait il a pris la voiture quand même
80 km à l'est au tour à nouveau pour
tester sa vision après le le coc vite
gommé n'était pas sûrement en même temps
et d'embarquer son enfant et son épouse
et c'est ça qui ne passe pas la presse
est furieuse même des pics pu du mexique
ont soutenu johnson et communes
réclament sa démission et le
gouvernement de johnson a fait une chute
de 20 % dans certains sondages ce week
end pourtant pourtant boris johnson ne
le lâche pas comment expliquer cet
attachement à canning
bah écoutez il ya deux choses concède
pour les johnson c'est qu' il n'est pas
fidèle c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
on sait même pas combien d'enfants
il a et et deuxièmement il aime bien
être populaire alors à mon avis comme à
quelque chose cette à conjecturer mais
il ya ce rapport sur l'algérie ans rue
stendhal fade
johnson refuse de puig et en dépit des
injonctions du parlement même peut-être
c'est la conjecture mais il doit y avoir
quelque chose peut-être comme lui dit si
tu me fais sauter je te fait sauter avec
on laisse en fuite et le contenu de ce
rapport
en tout cas si seulement il y avait une
expression en anglais pour il ya
anguille sous roche des années alors
merci beaucoup alex a bouffé sourire et
doit partir que wings d'amour c'est tout
le sujet démocratique de l'exemplarité
moi je crois qu'il faut être exemplaire
mais qu' on peut que tout le monde est
humain donc merci beaucoup mounir
majorie merci jérôme combine d'être venu
sur le plateau de lcp
on va parler à présent du quotidien des
femmes et des hommes il y en a des
hommes de ménage le député françois
ruffin défend une proposition de loi
pour améliorer leurs conditions de
travail son texte a été vidé de sa
substance c'est courant en matière de
textes de l'opposition ça s'est passé ce
matin et c'est la république en marche
qu'il a vidé de sa substance alors il
est très très en colère vous allez
devoir il a accepté de débattre dans un
instant avec un député de la majorité
mais d'abord voyez le reportage de
nathalie gloire et clément un père mo
ils ont suivi un homme de ménage qui
travaille à l'hôpital reportage mais ce
affaires non classées mon t-shirt mon
pantalon et mes chaussures et en dessous
voir il est 18h30 et mustapha se rend à
son travail
agent de propreté dans un hôpital depuis
cinq ans il est à l'image des femmes de
ménage que françois ruffin défendant sa
proposition de loi
à 57 ans cet homme de ménage travail de
nuit de 20h à 6h du matin donc là je
vais prendre la voiture parce que je me
déplace en voiture en espérant que le
périph soit pas trop bouger donc on est
parti
des horaires difficiles d'autant plus
qu'il s'ajoute un temps de transport
conséquent on sait pas trop bouché bée
une heure
et quand la circulation
n'est pas fluide je mets une heure
trente après un déplacement qui lui
coûte 250 euros par mois en essence
c'est
c'est mon choix mais hors de question
pour lui de prendre les transports en
commun j'aurais
plus de changements à faire puisque j'ai
de vue ça prend des deux trams bus déjà
fatigués avec des horaires de 10h
s'il faut mettre encore deux heures
chez moi les journées sont courtes
tous les jours on se tape à désinfecte
des boks d'opérations un travail
essentiel qui manque de reconnaissance
selon lui il gagne 1500 euros net
environ par mois un salaire qui comprend
16 heures de nuit majorée de 20% entre
21h et 6h du matin le travail de nuit
n'est pas reconnue du tout on est là
pour faire une prestation on est des
pions les conditions de travail ne sont
pas les mêmes que la journée façon d
livrés à nous mêmes aussi et ça c'est
vraiment un stress on doit prendre des
initiatives et
et tout ça c'est pas payé c'est pas donc
on vit tout le temps avec le stress donc
aux personnes qui disent que 20% c'est
bien moi je veux bien mais bon qui
viennent travailler la nuit après on
verra
il est bientôt 20 heures mustapha se
rend à l'hôpital sa journée de travail
va pouvoir commencer
bienvenue sur ce plateau françois ruffin
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes député insoumis de
la somme c'est vous qui portez un texte
pour revaloriser ces hommes et ces
femmes de ménage et pas simplement par
de la reconnaissance par du sonnant et
du trébuchant on va on va y venir
bonsoir gaël le bellec et merci d'être
là vous êtes député la république en
marche d'ille et vilaine et puis
derrière son écran nous attend géraldine
woessner pour sa chronique tout à
l'heure est ce qu'elle est avec nous
géraldine pas encore sûr à la voilà les
magies des webcams en direct
journaliste au point bien évidemment on
va parler de votre texte dans le détail
on va y revenir mais je voudrais savoir
pour rebondir un peu sur le sujet
comment comment vous est venue de
défendre ses personnages rappellent et
je précise que que cette proposition de
loi elles datent d'avant le coc vide
d'abord il ya les gens qu'on rencontre
dans son coin et donc qui vous font part
de leur quotidien de leurs horaires
compliqués parce que c'est presque un
privilégié entre rim et la personne
qu'on a vu elle travaille en continu de
nuit certes de nu mais en continu jeu
bons et il ya plein d'horaire qui sont
en fait avec les normes amplitude tôt le
matin tard le soir
on essaie de cumuler les boulots pour
s'en sortir bon ça c'est le quotidien et
ensuite par exemple il ya les lectures
du livre de florence aubenas le quai de
ouistreham qui de l'intérieur témoigne
de ce cet écrasement de ceux qui sont
tout en bas donc voilà ça allait de soi
pour moi que de deux ans la durée de mon
mandat j'ai c'est de porter de sa mère
aux côtés d'autres métiers par exemple
comme auxiliaire de vie sociale
animatrice périscolaire beaucoup de
métiers féminins d'ailleurs qui sont des
métiers un peu marginalisé c'est vrai
qu'on est en tête cette phrase d'
emmanuel macron qu'il prononçait déjà le
16 mars
trop de métier alors je cite de mémoire
1 mais mal payés et peu valorisé
avant de venir sur les propositions de
détails concrets des mesures monsieur le
député est ce qu'il faut ça change sur
sur le couster est-ce qu'il faut que ça
change pour pour ça
femmes et ces hommes là c'est évident
c'est évident qu'il ya des sujets et moi
je remercie françois ruffin d'avoir mis
le sujet sur la table à la fois parce
que le sujet il doit être posée le prix
d'un appui quand même parler marlène
schiappa secrétaire d'état en a parlé
c'est un sujet qu'on ne doit discuter
sur lequel on doit avoir des objectifs
précis sur lequel on doit avancer et
françois option le fait avec passion
donc c'est intéressant d'avoir ce
débat-là n'emmener du débat
parlementaire sur le sujet je crois que
c'est l'occasion de le faire alors il le
fait avec passion mais n'était pas très
content de la manière dont dans ce texte
a été vidé de sa substance si on va on
va vous voir très en colère mais dans
quelques instants on va parler du texte
pour lui demander pourquoi il ya aussi
simplement ce qui se passe dans les
étages du dessus
vous savez quand vous discutez avec les
femmes de ménage et là il leur fit je
paye et qu'elles sont à 740 euros 781
euros 780 euros
dans l'assemblée nationale là où nous on
est payé 5800 euros
à un moment on ne peut pas en ressentir
autre chose qu'une honte et de canton
s'interrogent sur leur quotidien et
qu'elle nous dit bah voila je me lève à
4 heures du matin je prends un but je
prends le train je prends le rer des
fois je pleure je viens pour trois
heures trois heures à 10 euros ça fait
trente euros et je rentre chez moi je
veux dire là il ya sous nos pieds
puisqu'on les micros les le carrelage
vient suite il ya une injustice y est
devant nous autant dire qu'avec
l'épidémie ce travail est évidemment
encore plus important puisqu'il s'agit
de de faire en sorte que tout soit tout
soit propre
je voudrais qu'on parle du texte vous
pouvez vous expliquer il ya une mesure
phare dur sur la première on parlait
parlons d'abord des horaires les
horaires décalés et des 50 % de
majoration vous réclamez précisons des
choses faut savoir que 97% des femmes et
hommes de ménage travaillent en horaires
décalés c'est à dire en gros entre 6h et
9h le matin et entre 18h et 21h le soir
puisque il cumule de boulot avec donc
une amplitude horaire qui fait que ce
qui détruit la vie familiale en plus
d'avoir un mauvais salaires il ya une
destruction la vie familiale
donc c'est comment on fait alors que
tout le monde considère que c'est un
problème
les syndicats de salariés les salariés
les patrons le syndicat de patrons qui
nous dit depuis 2008 on fait des tables
rondes on invite le ministère tout le
monde se met autour de la table mais ça
n'avance pas moi ma proposition c'est de
dire eh bien les oreilles entre 6 et 9
heures du matin et entre 18h et 21h le
soir ils vont être payés 50 % de plus et
de cette manière là ça va inciter les
donneurs d'ordres l'assemblée
nationale les universités l'hôpital à 10
rebonds on veut pas trop payés donc on
va réintégrer les femmes de ménage des
donneurs de la dre précis donc c'est
l'entreprise dans laquelle ces femmes et
ces hommes de ménage travail mais dont
elles ne sont pas salariés directement
puisque souvent ce sont des entreprises
de sous traitance qui les emploient
directement on va rester simples sur des
50 % de majoration
pourquoi ces noms alors le message il
est très très clair la question est la
volonté elle et qu'on puisse passer et
on le voit dans cette personne à moi
j'ai travaillé de nuit
vous savez on dit souvent quand on fait
des études statistiques que le travail
entre minuit et 5 heures il est perdu à
la fin de sa vie et vous regarder des
gens qui ont fait leur l'ensemble de
leur carrière de nuit c'est là pour toi
non parce que le nom il est qu'on veut
aboutir à du travail de entre 9h et 18h
à l'image du télétravail
l'idée c'est de dire par défaut le
travail ce travail là c'est travaillera
il doit travailler on connaît la suite
elle a travaillé pour les femmes de
ménage en journée la salle on peut
peut-être être incitatif parce que si
vous demandez 50 % de plus pour ces
horaires décalés très tôt le matin ça va
pas forcément très le télétravail ses
cachets bleus télétravail est l'occasion
justement d'être pendant le cours
navires us d'avoir développer le
télétravail parce que c'est inciter et
c'est obligatoire sauf à expliquer que
ce n'est pas possible institut t on voit
bien comment le télétravail il a avancé
énormément l'idée c'est de faire la même
chose comme l'ont fait les pays
nordiques avec des grosses discussions
justement avec l'ensemble des
partenaires et ils ont réussi à mettre
en place aujourd'hui un pays nordique
c'est 90 95 % et me françois ruffin le
rappelait ce matin en d'audition voilà
ils ont réussi ce travail-là par la
négociation nous apparemment on veut pas
les voir ces personnes peut-être qu'il
faut s'interroger là dessus géraldine
elle a passé pas mal de coups de fil
aujourd'hui à des à des employeurs et
des patrons d'entreprises de nettoyage
ils en pensent quoi tu cette proposition
des 50% de plus cher pour pour les
horaires tôt le matin ce qui frappe un
peu tout le monde sait que depuis deux
ans déjà le sujet revient régulièrement
sans que les choses avancent alors on
peut dire que c'est à cause d'un
gouvernement méchant qui méprisent à ce
personnel
je pense que c'est un peu plus nuancé le
constat tout le monde le partage
oui les conditions de travail des agents
d'entretien 550 mille emplois quand même
l'a pas dit quasiment invisibles sont
difficiles 85 % sont en cdi deux tiers
de temps partiel dont concrètement
monsieur rufin l'a très bien dit les
gens arrivent à 6 heures du matin ils
travaillent deux heures il repart qui
reviennent le soir tout le monde
voudrait que ça cesse c'est humain mais
la réalité myriam c'est que personne
n'est vraiment prêt à en payer le prix
précisément c'est à dire gagner la
france insoumise veut pas j'aurai les
heures supplémentaires mais sans peser
le fait que l'état emploie plus de la
moitié de ses personnels il est impec
unieux l'état il n'a pas forcément
étrangère évolutions techniques
personne ne veut payer et puis en marche
veux laisser ça à la négociation
collective alors menacent l'emploi est
alors de devoir justifier son refus des
heures de jour alors franchement même
les patrons des patrons auxquels j'ai
parlé ont trouvé ça franchement assez
nous le vrai problème finalement c'est
que nos députés vous messieurs vous
n'arrivez pas à construire ensemble une
stratégie pour faire bouger les choses
on a besoin stratégie parce que le
problème et sociétal qui refusent ces
horaires ramasser à la journée ne se
sont pas les patrons ce sont les clients
des entreprises de nettoyage des
salariés de ses clients qui ne veulent
pas qu'on passe l'aspirateur quand ils
sont au téléphone qu'on leur demande de
lever les pieds sous leur bureau qui
râlent quand des toilettes sont bloqués
une heure dans la journée on a
collectivement les français une
révolution culturelle en verre pour
admettre que ben oui cette personne qui
fait le ménage elle a autant le droit
que moi d'avoir une vie à leurs amis de
voir ses enfants et que ça ça implique
que je m'adapte vite filé là un problème
d'autres en dessous oui je voudrais
juste vous interroger sur cette question
culturelle et puis vous nous direz
géraldine comment ça se passe ailleurs
pourquoi pourquoi on arrive à avoir des
fesses de ménage dans des bureaux à 15h
de l'après midi et pas nous cl et il est
culturel ce sujet là
il est culturel mais il est quand même
aussi économiques ça a été dit le voilà
il ya eu un enjeu qui a été fait depuis
vingt ans de d'externalisation de sous
traitance pourquoi pour aller gratter
je suis désolé mais d'aller gratter sur
les personnes qui sont les plus fragiles
et qui occupent des emplois nécessaires
utiles et essentielle mais en même temps
qu'on peut par le jeu de la loi du libre
marché
aller chercher moins cher donc voilà
comment ça c'est fait et on a on a été
grattée surtout ça moi je pense qu'en
effet on le mesure très bien du coup à
la france insoumise que ça va avoir un
surcoût pour l'état mais je veux dire
quand on est capable de donner 5
milliards pour renault
quand on est incapable de donner 8
milliards pour l'industrie aéronautique
est ce que quand on constate qu'il ya
une injustice et une injustice majeure à
la fois sur les salaires et sur les
horaires on n'est pas capables là d'être
exemplaires et de lâcher un peu sur
cette question-là atouts lesquelles je
voulais vous dirai pas ce qu'on va voir
cet extrait ça vous a mis en colère mais
vous êtes coutumier du fait il faut le
dire parce que on a en mai l'habitude
est ce que vous poussiez des coups de
gueule dans l'hémicycle je voudrais vous
interrogé là-dessus on va vous re on va
vous revoir parce que c'était non sur
cette proposition majoration de 50%
et puis c'était non également pour que
les femmes de ménage même employés par
des sous-traitants puissent bénéficier
des conditions sociales des entreprises
dans la quête fond de ménage regarder
votre action vous réagissiez après vous
venez de vider complètement le texte moi
j'avais deux mesures un c'était on
survalorise les heures tôt le matin et
tard le soir
vous l'avez viré c'étaient les
conditions de salaires à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise sont les mêmes pour le
sous-traitant vous l'avait viré vous
changer de titre y a plus parlé
d'encadrement ya plus parler de sous
traitants si la plupart une maltraitance
et à la fin ça serait supposé être mon
texte
qu'est-ce qui vous aiment bien à ce
point en colère parce que ça arrive
souvent
vous êtes jeune et rien mais vous savez
déjà il ya que faut pas nous prendre
pour des imbéciles quand même soit on
vide complètement le texte on change de
titre et on vous dit que c'est vous qui
allaitent le rapporteur dans le mythique
s'est pas posé la présidente c'est une
manière mission c'est une manière de
faire et en plus on ironise ah bah tiens
vous votez contre votre texte forcément
ça plus rien à voir avec le texte qu'on
avait au départ médias
il ya une volonté aussi de faire parler
non quand la main moi j'aime et je suis
désolé mais je venais de toute façon
sans illusion je viens sans illusion
parce que j'ai pas d'illusion sur la
majorité mais je viens venait sans
illusion sur le fait qu'une proposition
soit adoptée
en revanche je me disais qu'est ce
qu'ils vont proposer en face est ce le
vide c'est le vide alors donc sais c'est
que c'est que on enlève mais deux
articles et on met du vide à la place si
on m'avait un amendement sur le sucre
vous donner au dialogue social six mois
plus tard venu il y avait la question
financière de la sueur majoration des
heures avant après moi un l'objet il
n'est pas compenser la pénibilité
l'objectif il est qu'on puisse
travailler de 9h à 18h donc ce serait
laisser les gens en mal très dense que
dire oui on surcompensé du coup bah on
laisse et on accepte une situation et
vous voilà changer là vous voyez bien
que c'est un moyen de l'autre un jeu
revient si ça met beaucoup plus obligé
c'est une contrainte aussi d'objets et
dire il faut motiver si c'est pas
pousser et déjà qu'on est l'édition là
aujourd'hui
ça va permettre aux gens de réfléchir
vous ont fait confiance au dialogue
chose je regarde cette édition qui sont
justement à mettre est à dire au bout de
six mois au bout d'un an ou deux ans et
ckoi l'édition est ce qu'on a eu des
discussions avec les syndicats et je
voulais revenir sur ça parce que pour
moi c'est le plus important je vais
revenir sur l'idée vous avez dit tout à
l'heure et françois ruffin l'adie vider
le texte ça veut dire quoi moi j'ai
remonté juste un tout petit peu en amont
parce que ce qui est dommage de la
france insolite c'est d'empêcher le
travail parlementaire parce que vous
avez dit que le texte
il a été travaillé avant moi le texte a
été déposé à l'assemblée le 12 mai donc
on aurait aimé le travail et le temps
est probablement c'est peut-être pour ça
que peu françois ruffin pas mais c'est
un modèle s'appelle simplement cette
question c'est inconcevable de voter ne
serait ce qu'en partie
un texte de l'opposition qui va
forcément les assemblées il taperait du
repubblica mais est ce que c'est parce
qu'elles détaillent c'est vrai que c'est
pas très fréquent j'aurais aimé parce
qu'on a travaillé aussi sur une
proposition de loi sa collègue
clémentine autain sur les cantines que
je connais plutôt bien sur lequel on a
validé plus la moitié des articles et la
france à sion il a refusé de mettre à la
niche de la semaine prochaine du coup en
urgence on est obligé de rajouter
d'autres textes comme celui-là qu'on
prépare touche mal parce que françois
ruffin il n'a pas pu auditionner les
syndicats c'est dommage de ne pas
auditionner les syndicats allaient
revenir juste parce que l'âme est
important ça en un mot c'est que ça
donne une légèreté finalement et une
gesticulation qui
essaye de compenser de l'impréparation
mais ça c'est pas acceptable c'est à
dire que on doit tous ensemble et quand
vous dites peut-être donné témoin il y
avait trois articles le premier est
serait intéressante de dire à votre
collègue journaliste est ce que les
entrepreneurs ils ont dit que c'était
possible de mettre en place le premier
quand vous êtes entrepreneur c'est pas
possible mettre en place comment
quelqu'un qui travaille dans 55
entreprises
il pourrait dépendre dépendre de cinq
conventions collectives différemment
mais comment alors comment sur le temps
de travail
il ya des temps de travail qui sont
lisses a l'air détendu le mensuel va
laisser agir lui jacobins géraldine
aller c'est comme quand vous parlez aux
syndicats et aux entreprises c'est pas
une loi qu'elle vous demandez vous
demande un accompagnement en finlande en
suède le travail de jour c'est la norme
pour les femmes de ménage elle travaille
de 6 heures du matin à 16 heures comme
tout le monde
plus proche de nous la belgique a à une
approche constructive c'est que avant de
faire des lois ils ont fait des études
ils les ont interrogés pour cerner les
problématiques tout ce qu'ils avaient a
changé en termes d'organisation du
travail parce c'est énorme tout ce qui a
changé
et ensuite une grosse campagne de
communication a été lancée dans l'est
dans les bus dans les cinémas pour
forcer la prise de conscience de ceux
qui travaillent aux côtés de ces gens de
ménages en france n'a jamais décollé et
ça n'a pas décollé sans doute du fait de
ces joutes politiques qui vont perdre du
temps parce que vous n'arrivez pas à
avancer ensemble
merci je trouve ça vraiment dommage non
mais c'est important donc article on
peut pas le mettre en place
article 2 il a été voté avec un
amendement de françois ruffin d'accord
article 3 on n'a pas le même jeu
offensif on n'y va pas pareil on pense
comme le télétravail
il faut obliger et expliquer si on peux
pas alors je suis d'accord avec votre
collègue on aurait dû le travailler plus
en amont il a été déposée il ya quinze
jours c'est difficile mais dire un texte
a été vidé aller alors qu'il ya plus de
la moitié avaient été gardés vous avez
pas vous laisser compris vous aurez le
mot de la fin vous portiez ce texte sans
surprise
vous êtes dans l'opposition vous n'avez
pas été entendu et on entend qu'il ya
une piste côté dialogue social mais
d'abord moi il ya un ministère du
travail a un ministère de l'égalité
hommes femmes
donc je veux dire si ça fait trois ans
qu'ils sont vos affaires ça fait trois
ans qu'ils pouvaient agir sur la
question ça fait trois ans que rien n'a
été fait moi je suis un petit député de
l'opposition
je viens présenter des textes parce que
ça correspond à ma sensibilité
j'entends qu'il ne soit pas la
perfection incarnée mais entend en tant
qu alerte bien je fais mon travail d'
alerte est pour l'instant ce que je vois
c'est le vide en face ce qui est proposé
quand on renvoie la négociation
collective qui ne fonctionne pas entre
eux parce que les salariés n'ont pas de
capacité de pression sur le donneur
d'ordres lui-même c'est-à-dire ici les
femmes de ménage de toute façon elles ne
peuvent pas faire pression sur
l'assemblée nationale elle même est de
même dans les hôpitaux
donc l'année se gausse ciation une
collective ne marche pas ce que nous
demandent les syndicats c'est une loi
qui viendra qui permet d'encadrer
aujourd'hui la le comportement de la
majorité en revoyant en voyant comme ça
c'est pour ce pilote
on sait qu' un rapport de force qui est
complètement déséquilibré en défaveur
des salariés qui sont qu'être
complètement et crache des et on sait
que demain dans six mois dans un an dans
deux ans ça va continuer non c'est dit
rendez vous dans quelques mois on verra
si oui ou non ça continue où cela ne
continue pas on a dit non merci je
proposerais bien vite dans un an
rendez-vous dans un an ici ou alors pour
la journée internationale du droit des
femmes parce que ce soit 80 blair rendez
vous de mars
rendez vous le 8 mars elle ici et on
voit comment le 12 cm selon françois
ruffin merci on va parler maintenant
d'un autre sujet vous savez qu'une
commission d' enquête qui a été acté
hier soit vous restez avec nous françois
de faim sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire et c'est thomas desprez qui
nous raconte tout ça n'est ce pas thomas
où êtes vous ce soir d'un bien même
cette commission denquête elle débutera
ses travaux dans quelques jours je vais
vous expliquer jingle
[Musique]
alors vous le savez peut-être depuis
deux mois les députés sont réunis en
mission d'information sur l'impact la
gestion et les conséquences dans toutes
ses dimensions de l'épidémie de
coronavirus ils ont mené cette audition
de ministres représentants syndicaux mer
ou encore de scientifiques
ils ont maintenant fini leurs travaux et
comme l'avait promis richard ferrand la
mission d'information va changer de
forme on a mission pourra se voir
confier les prérogatives des commissions
d'enquêté qui sera amené à évaluer
l'impact des décisions prises par les
pouvoirs publics et à retirer les
enseignements de cette crise sans
précédent alors cette commission
denquête elle a des pouvoirs très
important convocation obligatoire sous
peine de sanctions pénales audition sous
serment pouvoirs d'investigation bref un
vrai travail d'enquêteur et ce sont les
députés les républicains qui ont demandé
que la mission d'information se
transforme en commission denquête dès
maintenant
alors on est allé rencontrer leur
président bonjour damien abad
il était temps que cette mission
d'information se mue en commission
denquête oui c'est notre demande au
départ on avait voulu attendre tout
simplement que l'épidémie ils
ralentissent il est hors de question
pour nous de faire une commission d
enquête pendant que nos personnels
soignants se bat pour sauver des vies
dans les lits de réanimation
donc je crois nous sommes prêts pour
mettre en place cette commission
denquête pour répondre aux attentes aux
questions aux interrogations légitimes
des françaises et des français il faut
apporter des réponses et des solutions
pour l'avenir et les députés les
républicains auront une place importante
puisque le rapporteur général de la
commission denquête sera issu de leurs
rangs mais cela ne plaît pas à tous les
groupes les députés communistes par
exemple parle de manoeuvre grossière
destiné à percuter la commission
denquête qu'ils avaient eux mêmes
demandé bonjour andré chassaigne alors
comme ça on vous a empêché de faire
votre propre commission denquête oui
parce que on a déposé le 8 avril
cette commission denquête le droit de
tirage et pas de nouvelles la commission
des affaires sociales on voit bien on
voit bien que la majorité a voulu gagner
du temps et n'a pas voulu que d'autres
commission d' enquête démarre or c'est
un droit constitutionnel et du coup
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
on sait donc opposants il va y avoir un
débat dans l'hémicycle avec intervention
du gouvernement
et avec mon intervention qui explique
pourquoi on à manifester notre
opposition
et puis un porte parole je sais pas ça
serait semblable mains des républicains
sur pour contrecarrer ce que l'on peut
faire valoir
alors du côté de la majorité pour eux il
n'y a pas de sujet l'essentiel c'est le
fond le temps dans lequel on se trouvait
pas à tant de polémiques ou de débats
sur les procédures que qui doivent être
celles du parlement le parlement se
saisit d'une commission denquête pour
aller regarder dans le détail ce qui a
bien fonctionné et ce qui a moins bien
fonctionné
les oppositions sont évidemment
naturellement associés pour apporter
toutes les réponses et tous les
éclairages nécessaires aux françaises et
aux français dans la gestion de la crise
cette commission denquête elle va
débuter ses travaux dans quelques jours
et durera six mois mais ça on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler dans ma journée
à l'assemblée
voilà les députés ont six mois pour
enquêter pour convoquer des ministres le
premier ministre essaie de comprendre ce
qui s'est passé notamment au début de la
crise avec la pénurie de masques et de
tests vous fait confiance à cette
commission denquête pour parvenir à
éclaircir certain nombre de points
j'aurais bien voulu que la commission
lankaise du groupe communiste aussi
puisqu'elle avait été réclamée c'est un
droit de tirage je vois pas pourquoi ils
n'ont pas eu ça permettrait ce
pluralisme
c'est la première chose ce que je veux
dire là c'est que aujourd'hui encore on
a un souci dans la gestion de la crise
c'est à dire que dans l'est sur blues
par exemple des soignants ce sont
toujours des bénévoles chez moi dans mon
coin qui fabrique les sur blues s'est
toujours pas approvisionnée par l'état
donc ça veut dire que c'est faux pas ne
faut pas faire comme si c'était terminé
c'est toujours pas normal bon moi je lis
ça à la désindustrialisation voulu du
pays
ces trente dernières années quoi c'est à
dire que pour faire le lien avec les
femmes de ménage en fait on a contribué
à dégrader les métiers des classes
populaires à la fois plutôt masculin
dans l'industrie et féminin dans le
tertiaire et c'était le grand mouvement
qui au fond est au coeur du malaise
français
le malaise français des gilets jaunes
c'est l'écrasement des bas salaires
c'est la peur que demain on vivre moins
bien et finalement le le la crise du coc
vite pour l'essentiel sur ces produits
là c'est une crise de l'industrie
vous avez vu que
président de la république craindrait
selon selon certains papiers de presse
une candidature un peu trublionne pour
2022 à la beppe grillo un comique à la
coluche jean marie bigard aujourd'hui
par exemple dit qu'il était ouvert à la
possibilité ça vous inspire quoi
sa musique m'inspire que l'histoire elle
s'est ouverte mais déjà quand troublions
aussi qui s'est présenté en 2017 et qui
l'a emporté par effraction celui même
qui le dit donc voilà on a une histoire
qui est ouverte et c'est pas toujours la
même histoire qui se doit se répéter
faire il vous intéresse cette histoire
ben oui je moi ce qui m'intéresse je les
dis je le répète c'est d'ouvrir un
chemin d'espérance
entre l'extrême droite et l'extrême
argent entre maquereau et le pen il faut
ouvrir un chemin
voilà voilà mon objectif qui est clair
qu'ils n' est pour demain mais s'est dit
merci de rendez-vous est pris pour un
droit de suite sur ce dossier des femmes
de ménage on termine comme chaque soir
avec le jour d'après ce soir le thème on
va s'intéresser à la question du deuil
comment at on pu notamment juste au
début de la crise laissé les malades
seules à l'hôpital et parfois faire des
enterrements sans qu'il y ait la dignité
nécessaires de la présence des familles
c'est le psychanalyste et psychiatre
serge hefez qui a la foi témoigne et
nous livre ses analyses regarde
[Musique]
on vous laisse dans mon bureau devant
vague devant ma bibliothèque médiathèque
oui oui c'est un joli décor bonjour
serge st jo c'est la question de la mort
et du deuil qui sont complètement
bouleversé dans cette crise sanitaire
que l'on va aborder avec vous les rites
les cérémonies les hommages après
comment les réinventer d'abord la france
a été donc un temps ce pays qui n'a pas
permis à la fois d'enterrer ses mort
dignement et d'accompagner ces malades
en fin de vie vous le psychanalyste et
le psychiatre est aussi l'homme que vous
êtes n'a jamais accepté cette décision
pourquoi
d'abord je n'ai pas accepté sur un plan
personnel parce que j'avais moi même une
vieille maman d pad qui a été touchée
par le par le virus donc j'ai vécu
personnellement ce que pourrait être ce
drame ce que pouvait être le drame du
confinement des personnes âgées avec qui
on n'avait plus de contact depuis des
semaines alors que j'avais des contacts
quasiment quotidiens avec elle et le
drame d'apprendre qu'elle est malade
sans avoir la possibilité d'aller la
voir
heureusement j'ai pu user moi de mon
statut de mes prérogatives de médecins
pour passer les dernières heures avec
elle et je me suis rendu compte à quel
point c'était important
à quel point finalement c'était de
l'ordre de notre humanité de l'ordre de
la dignité de nos sociétés d'accompagner
nos parents nos grands parents jusqu'à
la fin de leur vie comme ils nous ont
accueillis quand quand nous sommes venus
au monde et j'ai mesuré la la au fond la
folie dans laquelle on était avec ce
virus
c'est à dire c'est comme si la peur que
cette épidémie a provoqué on peut le
comprendre nous avait fait perdre tous
les cadres normaux de ce que sont les
rapports humains et de ce conte sont les
rapports dans une famille bien sûr faut
prendre des précautions bien sûr il faut
mettre des masques il faut la
distanciation il faut prendre toutes les
précautions nécessaires
mais couper complètement les liens avec
nos parents c'est c'est c'est de la
démence
cette question de l'accompagnement du
dernier adieu de l'ultime présence
elle dépasse largement la question
d'aidé en deux
l'année de l'ordre de notre civilisation
c'est toute notre civilisation il n'y a
pas une seule civilisation digne d'être
appelé civilisation qui n'a pas inventé
tous et tous ces cultes et ses rituels
autour de la fin de vie et tout cet
accompagnement des morts c'est ça fait
vraiment partie de notre dignité de
l'être humain fait le lien qui nous
relient c'est çà et là cet
accompagnement entre la vie et la mue
c'est ce lien à l'autre qui nous
accompagne depuis notre naissance et qui
est notre oxygène
alors on a besoin on a besoin évidemment
de cet oxygène pour respirer
on a besoin de ce lien pour se sentir
vivant et se sentir exister le bébé dès
qu'il sort du ventre de sa mère il a
besoin d'être tenus d'être contenu
d'être choyé d'être bercé d'être nourris
et ça continue tout au long de notre vie
c'est le même lien qui se transforme
tout au long tout au long de notre vie
et plus on gagne en âge plus on revient
peut-être à ses besoins fondamentaux du
nourrisson où on n'entend pas bien on a
peur on est angoissé on n'a plus besoin
de l'autre besoin de toucher d'être
caressé d'être regardée et salé les
tablettes et autres et autres réseaux
sociaux ni par yann piat sûr que non
alors évidemment c'est mieux que rien
d'avoir un contact par par skype que
rien du tout mais on le voit bien
moi moi moi je les bus avec avec ma mère
je l'appelais par skype tous les deux
trois jours mais ça lui disait rien elle
entendait une voile savait pas d'où ça
venait elle reconnaissait à peine qui
s'était elle regarder tous les côtés
pour savoir d'où venait cette voie enfin
bon ça s'accepte ça n'avait pas beaucoup
de sens alors que juste prendre la main
de l'autre même sans parler et avoir ce
contact corporel c'est beaucoup plus
important que les paroles échangées
bon c'est pour ça que vous l'avez fait
ce témoignage pour faire prendre
conscience des traumatismes qu'on allait
qu'on allait engendrer en continuant à
appliquer ce genre tout à fait tout à
fait parce qu'a priori j'ai pas de
raison parler de mes expériences intimes
comme ça devant à devant un grand public
mais ça m'a paru important de le faire
pour incarner un peu ce ce discours
autour de la nécessité de réformer cette
ses relations et cet accueil
aider auprès des personnes âgées et
heureusement j'espère y avoir un petit
peu contre ibm manière juste
diriez vous que tout a changé
aujourd'hui depuis le 13 avril c'est
vrai que le président de la république a
expliqué qu'on pouvait organiser une
présence des familles aussi bien dans
les ehpad quel hôpital
est-ce que vous avez un tir peu de
retours d'hectares oui absolument
ça ça ça a été très vite parce que les
familles je peux vous dire qu'ils ont
entendu le message pouvait pas savoir le
nombre de messages de famille que j'ai
reçus après mon témoignage par par mail
par par lettre par messages
téléphoniques des gens en larmes
téléphone qu'ils aiment et aidez nous
aidez nous on vit une situation
insupportable avec avec nos parents et
là évidemment les familles aient entendu
ce message ils ont massivement était
dans l'est dans les ehpad et dans les
maisons de retraite pour exercer ce
droit de visite vis-à-vis de leurs de
leurs parents vous disiez tout à l'heure
que être là jusqu'au bout relevait de la
civilisation de l'humanité que ces
règles d'une certaine façon pouvait
s'apparenter à une forme de barbarie et
ça ça remonte on voit bien le droit à
une sépulture très très loin dans
l'histoire on pense à antigone bien sûr
est ce que est ce qu'on peut s'en
remettre
parce qu'il ya des familles qui n'auront
pas pu profiter de ces nouvelles règles
moins drastique qu'elle quelles
blessures psychiques et demeure quel
traumatisme ya un traumatisme à gagne
blessure a beaucoup en ont témoigné
auprès de moi je pense que ce
traumatisme peut se situerait que ces
blessures peuvent dépenser si justement
quelque chose de civiliser s'organise
autour du deuil et autour de la
disparition lorsque nous sortirons de ce
confinement il est évidemment toujours
possible d'organiser des cérémonies des
soirées où on parlera du mort où on
échangera des lettres des hommages des
mots des photos des vidéos enfin bon
tout ce qu'on tout ce qu'on peut faire
autour de ça et où surtout le groupe
le groupe familial et amical pour à se
resserrer et éprouvée ensemble autour de
cette disparition parce qu'au fond c'est
ça le plus important dans les rituels
collectifs
c'est d'éprouver ensemble c'est cette
résonance émotionnelle entre toutes les
personnes qui ont connu le défunt et qui
participe à son des papes parfois c'est
très joyeux il ya beaucoup de rires qui
circule aussi parce qu'on évoque les on
évoque les bons souvenirs c'est pas
forcément quelque chose de 2,2 tragique
mais en tout cas c'est cette résonance
très particulière que le groupe peut
ressentir à ce moment là et puis il ya
les enfants les enfants face à un deuil
la perte d'un grand parent face à une
épidémie imprévisible
comment on fait avec les enfants qu'est
ce qu'on doit leur dire pour pour leur
faire accepter parfois un dock très
difficile dans lequel peut se mêler
aussi la culpabilité alors 6,6 à la
culpabilité
c'est difficile de ne pas lui
transmettre parce que les enfants le
sentons dans la façon dont on monte on
leur parle donc j'irai que le premier
travail des adultes c'est déjà de se
débarrasser de cette culpabilité qui ne
sert à rien il n'y a pas à se sentir
coupable on y est on y est pour rien par
rapport à cette histoire chacun a fait
du mieux qu'il a pu
et ça c'est important déjà de l'intégrer
ensuite et bien aux enfants les enfants
là pour eux la mort ça fait aussi partie
de l'existence on est bébé on devient
adulte on devient une personne âgée ces
personnes âgées bon mourir à un moment
ou à un autre et les enfants en ont une
conscience très précoce de cela même
s'ils se figurent pas exactement ce
qu'est ce qu'est la mort on peut pas les
protéger de ça on peut simplement leur
rappeler à quel point cette personne qui
n'est plus elle existe encore dans notre
esprit
elle existe dans notre conscience elle
et elle peut exister dans nos
conversations que ça fait pas de mal
d'en parler et on peut évoquer avec eux
tout ce qui a été important pour ces
personnes qui ont vécu un moment et une
vie plus aujourd'hui le jour d'après sur
ces questions si sensible de la mort ça
ressemble à quoi
écoutez je crois que toutes les familles
ont vécu quelque chose à quoi elles
n'étaient pas habitués qui est un
resserrement des liens famille qui est
quelque chose qui a donné une autre
texture a ressenti des liens dans les
couples et à l'intérieur des familles je
vous dirai pour le mans
or et pour le pire le meilleur c'est que
il s'est recréé dans beaucoup de
familles une espèce de cocon dans
lesquels on a réappris les liens les
liens affectifs dans lesquels les
parents ont eu une autre
un autre regard sur leurs enfants et les
enfants sur leurs parents et des
conjoints dans le couple le pire c'est
que il ya eu aussi évidemment beaucoup
de beaucoup d'intrication émotionnel des
uns par rapport aux autres beaucoup
d'empiétement des uns sur les autres
c'est tous ces éléments-là ces éléments
à la fois constructif et ses éléments
beaucoup plus destructeur qui vont être
un reprendre après merci beaucoup cela
que j'ai fait voilà pour cet entretien
ci s'achève cette émission merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve demain
pour un nouveau ça vous regarde
même lieu même heure très belle soirée
documentaire sur lcp et à demain
[Musique]